peu
m
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
à marjah ceux qui veulent ouvrir une
drôle de tête
si vous étiez pas collé contre la vie
je pourrais avoir ça fait
il est pour
merci
[Musique]
il a essayé
maman réponds moi qu'est-ce qui est
vachement vite zappé répit tu peux
attendre tapas deux ans moi je peux
atteindre mon regret c'est tout
si tu veux savoir moi aussi j'ai regardé
les temps mais là devants en troisième
position tu vois de quoi couper pouvoir
[Musique]
oh
voilà
ouais
[Musique]
ça fait longtemps que je dis
là bas tout le monde l'a compris le sens
des jaloux moi j'ai très mal
[Musique]
non
non la crise aussi un oui elle est belle
l'appel du yen au gésu la raison je sais
quand même pas qu'on l'appelle tout
tenté pour marcoussis
non en fait l'accord à sa première femme
je sais pourquoi
à propos la deuxième femme n'est pas
venu avec vous non non
non charlotte n'a pas pu venir avec vos
réponses
[Musique]
et tu repasseras paris oui je vais faire
mon atelier cia toute la nouvelle
collection en compte
je reste une semaine que je retourne à
munich
j'étais le contraste est venu puis je
viens de revoir les ans sans problème
charlotte et toi comment ça va
à eux deux
c'est par elle que ça ça va pas bien
arrangé par la passion et les vacances
on s'est passé simon pas ça quand même 1
cfoot vacances des super sport c'est une
tarte à la mire qui n'est pas lui la
prise est ce qu'on fait dans un cas
comme ça primo c'est dégueulasse de
cafter et deuxio si vous la partagez pas
batam éléments là vous allez où ce
n'était pas ma mère j'ai mis pas vue qui
baisse que ce pays et son pdg de trouver
passe à l'endroit idéal
[Musique]
alors
1er prix les écoles et ça
du concours tir
si on fait un rayon sera bientôt
l'équipe temps là que d'une
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
matin chez moi j'ai comme c'était parti
le petit prince harry lui chez casino
mercredi matin l'emprunt sa femme du
prince sans vie chez moi pour ma fille
à la suite de cette action revient dans
ce jeudi matin qu'en aval le petit
prince henri chinois ou le pouvoir
il
mais
com
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous
et
[Musique]
allez mon défaut
la leaf est pas la peine d enfants
[Musique]
il est bon
papa c'est moi qui suis au lit pour
appuyer pas puis si je veux un bon alors
ça démarre on se fait vieux parce que
quelqu'un sonne à l'éval enfin
bourigeaud mes séries mais j'aurai fini
mais tu vas retrouver des pièces de
bronze mais toujours les grands pour
charlotte
oui ça va j'ai passé de bonnes vacances
à vous de faire super bien mais manger
un cadeau pour toi préfère arriver plus
vite mais il y avait un monde fou
allez on va voir sa rentrée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous ai dit sans poiret pas tout
chien les instruments pas facilement la
suite et va bientôt manger les jolis
cadeaux mis les beaux coquillages pas
miss et regarder bouygues immobilier
olivo cailloux mais votre bac il faut
finir de décharger le rythme qu'il y
avait des noms enfin ses fruits et
chaque mois info que j'allais prendre la
tête
la bonne mine le soleil la mer
je suis pas une tête d'enterrement
alors alors on s'était donné les
vacances pour réfléchir et arriverait
quelle conclusion pour qu'on sait par
sérieusement oui oui bernard
sérieusement ça fait deux ans qu'on en
parle tous les hits à prendre une
décision j'ai pas ce sentiment là moi je
pensais que cela pouvait s'arranger
simplement avec de la patience d'un peu
de bonne volonté mais j'y crois
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi mais parce
que ce thème tout simplement moi
[Musique]
monsieur
mais coûte un moment donné l'amour face
qui plus est lourd à porter le chapelle
julienne mais non il s'agit pas de ça et
sa chique nous avons compris dans les
forêts pour enfants on va vous rezé
voilà qui seront collectés ils ont
besoin dans l'orthodontie c'est la barre
et le type seraient d'accord pour
reprendre mon cabinet à paris oui bah
voilà voilà
[Musique]
atrous 120 minutes et gonflé par des
machins l'argent mais alors pour les
bons fait pour une fête rentrait de
vacances est rentré de vacances pas
écoute me dis pas que tu en doutez pas
c'est pas parce qu'on se doute des trucs
ça vous fait plaisir quand ça arrive au
maire d' atteinte après toi moi est à
toi de moi
on a eu du bon
qu'est ce qui bloque jeter déclare des
tonnages et avait acheté ça pour un
anniversaire
ah ouais je me souviens c'est le
brouillard de la rue malebranche taille
posé le bouquin enveloppé sur une chaise
près de toi et qu'un clan qui avait
failli embarquer fait que sa serviette à
ses actes a dit que les paquets étaient
à toi à moi c'est demander qu'est ce que
ces textes le paquet on sent un peu le
coin parce que ça avait un qui était
pour moi le paquet ah ouais c'est mon
anniversaire
et c'est là que tu m'as donné j'ai pas
lécher pouvoir vient maintenant avoir le
temps j'ai vraiment décidé à aller à
sisteron
je crois que c'est mieux comme ça il
doit aussi tu fais un échange et avoir
déménagé
bah oui on va pas vous fait pas les
choses à moitié un petit d'enter dans le
coup avec moi ah bah merde c'est pas moi
qui vais partir citron et gonfler les
seins qu'on regarde tu appuyer sur le
bouton arrêt comme toi quoi
[Musique]
les enfants mais cherchez vous à fait
les autres sont dans leur base lyon
julien dubail la salade soit une chose
est pas paul ii a appelé les patrons à
rapporter les bougies et battu à lyon
après et vos appareils je peux voir
pendant la crise quoi au toit je viens
se porte la nuit
bon ça a pas l'air mal bien on va voir
ça dans le cabinet et toi paul va
falloir que je te fasse à notre appareil
et une autre en train bus et ben c'est
la fête là dedans laver et que tu as
veut dire cela à l'air parfait pas drôle
a continué regarder la nuit c'est
parfait dans pas mal voilà
lui par la femme
[Musique]
ces demandes et toi pourquoi on en est
là
non mais tu te regarde et ne put arriver
ici tu prend tout en main les enfants le
bas la bouffe non seulement tué leur
père mettez aussi leur mère et moi
qu'est ce que je deviens
[Musique]
malal nord
short autiste je redresse les dents mais
je n'ai soit une barre pour garder quand
même bon ça vas ouvre grand et dans la
nar tu te laves mal les plantes et plein
de tarte ou un laquelle met au fond à
droite car il n'est pas de doute non il
ya quand même chose qui doit être clair
entre nous puisqu'on en parle
je suppose que puisque tu as pensé à
tous à la séparation échanger son
cabinet tu as pensé aux enfants aussi
respire plus
oui j'ai pensé je prends les petites aux
hommes ont un passé parfois ils
s'arrêtent moi non mais non pas n'a pas
bouleversé leur vie et les ont remis à
sisteron et transparu t donc tu dis ça
parce que ça va dans ton sens une fois
de plus et que finalement tu t'arranges
toujours pour te retrouver avec les
enfants c'est bien ce qui est arrivé
avec génie avant que tu me rencontre
mais moi je ne suis pas joli
non mais c'est pas la même chose à toi
tu veux te barrer c'est ton problème ce
n'est pas le mien et celui des enfants
tu vois team exclu je compte pour du
beurre
je n'exclus pas géologique
il parle toujours
alors une fois qu'on a dit voir si comme
vous bof quoi ça fait entendre et des
forces et regarde papa ou maman
justement il discute mais ce n'est pas
triste
c'est vachement bien comportée mort
parce que vous avez deux maisons de la
lumière de noël de vacances de tout quoi
tu as une sacrée car il serait bien que
tu me posséderait que c'est toi qui
aurait les enfants moi je suis prête à
jouer le jeu mais toi voilà est-ce que
tu vas pouvoir te débrouiller tout seul
tout seul mais je me dis merde
et c'est hier et ce par ne reparlera
nahla j'arriverai
moi je sais pas si tu as envie de
divorcer ou de figures toi qu'on va pas
te demander ton avis un cd que ouais
c'est vrai on va pouvoir dire sur mon
vivant chez nous
[Musique]
cela ne se passe pas trop mal inspiré
de toi est ce que tu t'en sors
j'attends des nouvelles des enfants je
te rappelle qu'il faudra que
l'appartement soit disponible dans 10
jours au plus tard
je suis désolé que tu es si peu de temps
de retourner je te souhaite bonne chance
charpy
on
vous
[Musique]
durant tout va ça qu'est ce que tu vas
voir le bras tendu peut-être en profiter
pour lui demander une augmentation pour
compenser nous défendre a lancé hier
entre aesch à l'être bonjour je vous
mets sur le site monseigneur vous êtes
content oui je sais vraiment très
bientôt ce qui conseillait alors la
campagne c'est la fiche jeu je veux le
l'arc de triomphe vous voyez alors un
homme en slip monseigneur qui enjambe la
triumph et puis alors avec le slogan les
vacances sont finies rentrée à l'aise
avec le petit monseigneur vous voyez oui
c'est extra comme idée bon ben c'est
tout ainsi sa dette
[Musique]
bonsoir la passoire soir où elle est la
passoire
voilà un bon j'aime pas cette mare en
vous et pas face et pas fin tout à
l'heure tu as fait tu verras que tu te
forces à peu tu peux pas trop en
attendre à dire bon c'est bon tu vois ma
plus de dix jours pour trouver un
appartement
bon bah t'es donné pas ça on commencera
le lycée tout de suite oui oui la montat
jeu là pas mal du tout de suite hyper
mal à les gammes bonbons hendaye
[Musique]
ramallah
[Applaudissements]
oh la vache
dis donc raul ouais ça te dirait pas que
leur fils est sale et a dépassé les
gérants des voix 4 fonctionne pas ben
oui car on dit non nous savons que vous
seriez ne sais pas mais il n'en est en
fait pas d'eux portait tout ce qu'il a
rendez-vous à quatre mois et je compte
sur toi pour le strip and root
oui oh ben t'en fais pas pour leslie
plée qu'une parle
merci passe pas et ne fait pas attendre
[Musique]
c'est dans la dernière fois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
faites attention qui vous fait des
grimaces je serai pas me retrouver face
à face avec un malaise bah on sait pas
s'ils sont mineurs mais ils sont assis
oui on peut pas ce qu'on trouvera la
grosseur de la paix
mais 4h30 alors
depuis quand
5 heures ouais il est à paris
qu'est ce qu'il a répété que les quatre
heures et demie
elissa parce qu'il a failli qu'on n'a
pas douté
question d'acheter un tout
panis vie écoutez on a rendez-vous
vachement important info le trailer est
votre goûter vous allez l'oublier un
petit moment
n'empêche et les nuits je veux pas être
l'emmerdeur mais c'est pas l'heure de
goûter ici justement c'est l'heure enfin
je veux dire heureusement la suisse tel
moment
si on a faim tu as peut-être femme et
notre rendez vous est le plus important
c'est tout
menacée saturant mal je promets je
promets qu'après deux rendez vous je
vous fais un goûter sens à ces mots
biffés animation jeunesse
pourquoi pas ensemble signaux 2000 après
leur claque de choc
[Musique]
dur
tant le but
appréciez-vous la paix de la plage
[Musique]
tu vas génial or toi quoi banny il ya
plus de framboise bof chaker tout le
monde et barras te plaît
[Musique]
jorick faire pipi c'est facile tiens je
viens tout en occupant un modèle non de
ça
g berne le jeu et rien ne coûte rien
l'ado manager gerber ont sauté chalet
berlin chalette de même ma fille eva
s'est rendormi ça c'est mon fils paul la
petite famille tout cela
si vous alors voyons ça tout de suite il
s'agit de combien de pièces trois
chambres jeu ça me paraît bien j'aurai
ma chambre noire
tadic trois champs mais en effet alors
qu'il sait qu'on va pas ça change un
tant soit 3 ou 5 parce que c'est pas du
tout la même chose
l'ordinateur résout les problèmes si
vous les données qu'on y prenez alors
qui fait qu en a pas ça chambre on
n'aura pas ce que ça change
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
aura donc trois chambres à coucher
nous voilà partis je suppose que vous
voulez une cuisine qui soit une
véritable cuisine
oui alors une véritable piscine ça c'est
très important parce qu'on est 50
il faut penser à bat yam salam salut c
moi parisien anne hommel et pas alors
une cuisine qui sert une cuisine et
vient ensuite le sanitaire c'est quoi le
sanitaire défi la grande masse et
julienne et puis c'est typiquement un
charmant salle de bain toilette combien
de toilette et combien talibans
je veux dire en sac quand une salle de
bains et awc autre salle de bain ce sera
chouette mais c'est ça et puis une
baignoire avec aplomb soir et puis un
sauna remarquer avec un sauna nous avons
c'est quoi son art bien alors une salle
de bain 1 wc et c'est tout pas de wc
lorsqu'une matin il ya vachement foule
j'appuie pas de regrets non fiables
comment appuyer qu'est ce que ça fait ça
très compliqué c'est très sophistiqué
voilà alors nous voilà dans les salles à
manger une salle à manger je suis fou ça
me paraît normal a living à salon et y
accueille en mer on n'a pas besoin de sa
longue attente et qui est lui-même en
vrai et vous pointer là ce que vous
gagnez excellent parfait maison
l'ordinateur a parlé la maison idéale un
petit jardin du style résidence se
dresse l agence à claude mesure fera
baer exactement ce qui nous
[Musique]
une entrée tout à fait convenable en
examen et qui donne sur les petits tas
de sable qui portait une pelouse où le
fun
bellows tout à fait convenable elle est
vachement autres la tunisienne à ces
chaises papa enfin pierre pas comme ça
m'a pris mais alors tu as compris son
oncle est non j'ai pas compris les
enfants les enfants ne le vous disais
voilà le départ que tout à fait
convenable et qui impressionne beaucoup
de visiteurs on a rogné des services aux
diverses à une pelouse vrai pari si je
puisse vous remontez voilà un petit
héros tout à fait convenable et qui
donnent du cachet et ducasse et c'est
quand la maison un aspect un peu
original c'est une canalisation
extérieur mais tout à fait convenable
vadam entrer tout à fait convenable
on monte au nez c'est indispensable d'en
voir est entré comme je vous dise que ma
vie puisse y un porte - sauf assez c'est
assez bas je précède pas dit si le le
salon c'est extra la saint-thomas
submerge femme arrive si nous avons la
salle à manger tout à fait exact on
l'aperçoit de la cuisine la cuisine
parfaitement emmené à
la vérité sort de la bouche des enfants
allez on apprend taplin allait super
bien
c'est vrai qu'à côté vachement sympa sa
part la russie elle est très calme
à y bien reprise après qu'est ce qu'il
raconte qu'ils n'avaient pas très
justifiée je mens pas je le dis mais
convient 30130 mais feront plus éloignés
pour ses travaux ce qui est bien
le jardin encore clichy
allez papa on la france je crois que
cette maison vous convient tout à fait
écoutez vous n'êtes très sympathique et
si leur laissez vous aller
et laissez-moi vous proposer quelque
chose de tout à fait raisonnable voilà
j'ai un autre rendez vous et je vous
laisse ici vous visitez supputer tout à
votre aise c'est au moins en partie et
je vous laisserai les clés dans la boîte
aux lettres j'ai lutté à la guitare à
des matches où nous sommes vendredi
j'ai un autre client dans cette affaire
je vais m'arranger pour vous la garder
jusqu'à lundi sept maisons lors son fils
alain et y eut à 21h50 bien les gars
avec l'argent bien entendu ce n'est à
lundi j'espère non c'est vrai qu'elle
est extra cette baraque seulement alors
trente mille balles plus juste les
loyers de neuf ans plus tard sans
compter les travaux seraient chercher
dans les 40 50 ça pourrait trouver une
idée ici ont braqué la conduire ma mère
mais ça va pas mais ça va pas dans ta
tête hein
m'bah brac que la grand-mère des
bricoles
[Applaudissements]
dis donc en pleine forme en pleine forme
n'est ce pas les enfants la pêche
comment enfin de quoi les commissions
bien habillé jamais vu comme ça que
comme ils ont grandi à julienne tu vas
voir elle va bien tout mangé la soupe
sur la tête et il faut quand même pas
charrier 1 et on travaille ça va ça va
mais comment se fait-il que sherlock ne
soit pas venu elle va bien ah oui ou non
elle va bien elle va bien non n'est pas
venu c'est le boulot tu seras fallait
pas venu merci oui un petit peu parce
que c'est plus sain allons voyons les
baies la maison beaudry comme ça la
secte est vraiment en pleine forme
tuez le monstre écoute autrement je te
le dirais pas 1 les enfants j'espère que
vous allez rester tout le week-end
wissant chose c'est haut à droite et à
gauche il ya longtemps j'avais pas vu le
site flottante aussi peloton que celle
là est aussi appétissant l'année rien
dieu c'est délicieux marcquois je suis
pas très bon jour je suis très défaire
je suis bien triste que charlotte n'ai
pas pu venir à l'est de la cité ouais un
peu pas sisteron d'ici sisteron et
faciliteront assisteront belge crois que
tu vas me dire qu'ils produisent pas de
bonnes courses et qu'elle ne fermait pas
de gamine elle allie dans un collectif
avec pink hip hop l'un d'eux voulait
rien niko eeckhout voilà enfin j'aurais
surtout tu te fasses aucun mauvais sans
aucun problème tout va bien tout va
vraiment vraiment très bien c'est l'avis
phare charte et moi nous nous sommes
séparés
c'est paris charlotte et toi ou tu mon
dieu mais comment ça c'est pas vrai
offrir aux gens comment faire une
ovation
charlotte et toi maman on voit ça c'est
donc positif c'est pas tragique à la vie
ça arrive quoi toi ça ça t'arrive
souvent le problème troisième déménager
mon dieu mais les enfants on a décidé
qu'elle est avec moi comme avec jenny la
première fois j'ai même pas demander
comment il va jenny balle est toujours à
munich sont en affaire de prêt-à-porter
marche très bien d'état correspondant à
paris
elle vient souvent vers les enfants non
mais ça va bien alors tout voilà avec
quatre ans maintenant mais c'est bien
maman je t'assure formidable on est
vachement content d'être tous les cinq
on est triste mais on est vachement
content si voilà charlotte fait un
échange de cabinet nous on doit
déménager alors on a trouvé une maison
un million qui multiples il n'a pas la
preuve quand même 30 millions et tu
voudrais que je ne passe pas grand
vaisseau trente mille pattes rampillon
suhard ont alors ça doit être des
l'arbre et pour ce prix là c'est parce
que le type a dit qu'il n'en finit pas
et non mais non si le pas de porte
voilà on s'était dit que peut-être c'est
en 2030
ces votes il faut faire vivre inquiet et
je peux parler oui voilà ses 39 points
et nous les faut pour lundi avant lugeur
victoire puisque je les trouve ses
trente mille francs
oh
[Musique]
on a juste le temps les 9 heures quatre
mois j'ai fils de moi j'étais un et
c'est moi qui ai raison évidente que
cela y a plein d'argent et alors comme
ils savent qu'elle est un gros merde
les voilà non à la peine que toujours
accompagne fils je vais rentrer à pied
d'ailleurs j'ai quelques courses affecté
sur un et pas d'apprendre sur la route
t'inquiète pas maman
[Musique]
et pas si on arrive après divers
horizons tiens par exemple une minute
après 10 heures ça va
minutes après 10 heures ça va
et deux
même cinq mêmes dit ça va pas dix
minutes c'est presque un quart d'heure 1
17 à 10 enfin se dire 10h10 et pas 10
heures on a intérêt de pile à l'heure
puis il faut que j'aille bosser mois
autrement
mido va faire un salto qui s'habille
d'eau s'est passé papa on y sera dit ça
va pas j'espère s'il n'a pas attendu du
body casse la gueule mais les regards
1,42 presse que trois noms quand bientôt
dans les vaches
oh
[Musique]
moi jamais arrivé à l'heure il faut
pourtant
[Musique]
oh
devenir mère mais à 10h40
moi j'aime ça bon bah c'est trop tard de
cette pièce est tout à fait qu'on a
qu'est ce qu'il a à parler tout seul
maintenant il ya des gens
[Musique]
en fait ce qu'il fallait je suis désolé
nous avions convenu 10 heures je vous ai
attendu et la c ces messieurs-dames
gonflé non non c'est impossible
je suis désolé j'ai attendu le maximum
monsieur faber j'aimerais que le
discutions la question garage ces
garages de sont pas en façade un
frenchies d'absolument construire un
garage de façade j'en fais une condition
au plus toute façon elle convenait pas
n'était pas convenable à les enfants la
salle de bain
[Rires]
[Musique]
j'étais pourtant choisi
bon
[Musique]
magna
va de la mi mai
[Musique]
les dents et abou ayyoub rien arizona
tous
le
mais moi
[Musique]
et le présent
oh
[Musique]
m
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
en
e
ans
[Musique]
nous
à
et
ok
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
oh
le
[Musique]
un couplet
oh
les mains
m
oh
[Musique]
m
paul
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
g
[Musique]
ign il ya une seule heure devant dort
pas c'est là où ma grande
ouais dit ta mère bien comprendre ce
soir tu verras pas de quoi parler des
affaires est bon mais pas sur tout
notamment billets pour ce soir aux
vicois guesde et toi qu elle va donc il
parle protège les pôvs mobile et porte
un regard copains on en apprend tous les
jours
ben oui les moules et des bas et ce
matin je serai à bordeaux quai
[Musique]
ils ont fait jeu ce qu'on me dit de
faire avec les chères d'abord je
remballe
[Musique]
amy ma mère fille
non mais tu peux pas attendre que tout
va bien avec votre mère
bon on va partir en week-end super et si
mais sa détresse
c'est pathétique pourquoi ce bas monde
hip hop les rangs de la gauche ont les
nerfs non il n'en est pas question c'est
mon tour compte
[Musique]
toi tu n'es pas l'agent ce matin jacques
à la maison non séparation vous demain
matin le marché a très peu importe quoi
non c'est moi ouais vous prenez pas les
finales dans les tours par les to et
voilà c'est ça un mois juillet paul eva
est clair vu leur merde vous parlez non
ils sont avions arrivent à orcières
secteur et qu'on a il attendra victoire
bon bah on va s'engager partie entendue
[Musique]
alors voyons allons allons
a vous a reconnu avant moi c'est
terrible ce petit fait l'objet de soins
correct sinon j'avais sévir je vais
subir coup pour coup
[Musique]
biz pour des piges pour la gloire de
plus un tour de plus avoir de prise
maintenant je puise non la tour de pise
on souhaite plutôt que pour la faire la
course d'ici le printemps et l'automne
2010 la belle y fera vers la tente pour
la fête des mères ben ouais j'ai tu le
veuilles et sur la tour de pise
prochaine chez lui monsieur vidéo moi
j'ai pensé que je réalise ma 7e tour
s'écroule avec une rose à faire il me
faut c'est tout ce monde du roi avant ce
soir
oui tout ça n'est pas sérieux
je suis fait chier dessus et m'ont bien
de ce qui est super pied le grand calme
l'ambiance travailleuses entre
s'inquiète pas mais oui le racing
allô allô allô est toujours là et hélas
ouais il doit y avoir des parasites ou
alors celle adoptée dans le brouillard
pour une source
je remonte sur matoub oui c'est ça passe
je vous livre sa famille un bain dans
l'après-midi dans la famille liée à paul
toi parce que violent bideau 1,6 et
encore on ne parle des services
tranquille non
si ça vous dérange et je suis votre
voisine
je m'appelle s'allonge s'allonge bijoux
bonjour madame jeannette vous dérange
pas mais mon téléphone est en
dérangement
publiez votre bon je n'ai pas sans
l'autre soit je voudrais pas de visite
remonte votre voisin espaces naturels
mans c'est toujours quand on a besoin du
téléphone qui me refais pas retenu est
la toute façon maintenant tourner le
téléphone et personne à la tonalité d'un
travail c'était mon prénom en plein vous
oublie pas le bonheur aux animaux oui je
côtoie des maillots répondez moi non
plus sympathique envers cette union
12 rue des amandiers bo bébés rats et
des enfants souffrent tous top de
température merci je sais pas pourquoi
je dis vous avez des enfants aussi je
crois bien qu'on accable
j'en ai tâté les réclamations pour mon
téléphone ça serait bien de vous voyez
pas ah ouais je vous en prie sa salle
elles sont pas pressés enfin
et vous vous allez qui vit tout seul
vous en ferez c'est ça je serai là ils
répondent toujours corps et vous vous en
sortez très bien enfin j'veux pas trop
mal c'est pas mon mari qui restent à
lalo oui c'était pour séméria
dérangement non non je ne dis pas qu'ils
vont passer des services d c'est quand
même fou car ni quand les enfants sont
glissés oui oui bah moi quand ils sont
pas la folie et j'en profite pour
travailler
et justement aujourd'hui j'ai un boulot
ou urgent à ça les enfants cathy sarraï
a bien d'autres que ces questions soient
posées
et oui qu'est ce qu'on ferait sans
honneur pour marquer un peu de calme
c'est pas mal non pas que je me remette
la meilleure santé aux vôtres c'est
sûrement pas grave
merci
[Musique]
on en sera la grève quelques jours oui
monsieur c'est une bonne heure avant
politique c'est la grève comme ça sans
rien dire c'était prévu pas ça pour nous
parler de plomb tombe par monsieur avant
bâle - on en a pas beaucoup parlé et
monte plus ça
mon dieu
[Musique]
je veux tu faire quand enfin désigne tu
perdrais mon père s'excuse mais dès que
vous vous en foutez le se fait pas vrai
papa vendredi c'est quoi monsieur racing
pub c'est ma chatte pourquoi la chute
des cheveux
citons à titre de témoins journal c'est
un machin italien comtois gd choisi
l'appel consolidé
bon j'ai compris alors l'idée de la pub
c'est ça voilà c'est vous montrer en
action susceptible de saloperies sur mes
dessins bon alors la vie des stars
c'est à 10 cas rendez vous avec sa
petite amie au sommet de la tour depuis
sept et penser aux rares comme blague
alors il est au sommet de la tour de
pise et il a tu en voilà il attend et la
nana qui a tort ben tiens pas à la hague
est complètement idiot même complètement
c'est vraiment une dégaine alors il est
là il attend évidemment il est désespéré
à plus de deux heures de retard
un suiveur des gueules à venir au long
way elle arrive à l'aris ne va pas de
pub alors en veux tu en voilà
alors elle arrive et elle voit comme ça
agglutiné au pied de la tour
autour de quelque chose quelque chose
qui aurait pu tomber de la thuringe et
jean-marie celtic qui s'est balancé du
haut de la tour
ben voila voila c'est le type qui sait
celle qui sait pas annoncée vous voilà
libres la pub la voilà le type s'est
balancée et maintenant voilà interverti
et alors on voit les cheveux du type qui
tombe et la bulle s'est consolidée au
retard la chute des cheveux
[Musique]
si j'avais des petites choses a attendu
la la la bonne pas ils ont les vols
coiffant d'un but il est pas là tiens il
me disait ici super calme
ah bon alors pourquoi n'y ait pas la
folle route est d'une part nous tout est
pas grévistes car non à vous auriez fait
la tendre quand même bon allez
maintenant du vent parce que bideau lui
il est membre
[Musique]
il aurait la grèce intégrer la bêta nous
a prévenus n était plus et madame
maintenant les sept îles les plus à
marie soeur at il ajouté je n'ai pas de
marine corps et or il n'y avait pas je
ne sais pas danser j'aurais jamais faire
fort
[Musique]
en juillet on sera quand même bizarre
qu'ils sont parvenus déjeuner pour elle
ça commence à m'inquiéter moi papa et se
presser la cantine ne marque pas contenu
web
enfin je crois
[Musique]
alors oui oui mais c'est moi mais je me
cramponne à votre tour
mais bien sûr que vous l'avez oui oui
matt hill vous portez premiers dessins
ok voilà salut
en passant jette un coup d'oeil au lycée
il doit être dans les parages pas eddy
pas facile pour lui c'est lâche est un
grand coup d'oeil alors que l'ensemble à
gages commence à attaquer je retiens
talus et julienne étudiants raul que ce
soit suite ok je te suis pas qu'on va en
lit ça va être complet s'il fallait pas
à l'heure
[Musique]
je crois que doucement allô papa c'est
moi julienne écoute j'ai jeté un grand
coup d'oeil au lycée vayer pas papa paul
coûte chez un copain à la cantine et
super fermé bon bah à tout à l'heure
non non s'oublie pas maman oui ok mais
christiane question encore
[Musique]
mais c'est pas vrai ça peut pas passer
tranquille alors de quoi devenir dingue
qu'est ce que tu fabriques la hotoie est
bien monté comment démontrer non
[Musique]
il faut tous ces changements
non pas là par la force tout le temps je
ne suis pas de voix est douce mais
attention on va là mais pas les
mandchous quoi vous m'avez compris il ya
maintenant à la maison très plat ou
parents de partager la gamme avec moi
parce que moi figurez vous j'ai pas que
ça à faire occuper des bombes regrets
puisqu'il est bien ouais c'est ça pour
toi tu as compris 1%
[Musique]
avec un tel pas
les remercie y'a plus personne au jc
personne ne sait rien il faut qu'on soit
7 heures à orly
mais au petit bien être un chasseur
acteurs docteur voit bien que chine
marque par le docteur il est très occupé
j'étais inquiet aussi accès rien ma
fille et moi nous avons pourtant qu'elle
s'appelle cette petite fille madame eva
joly elle touche à laquelle je suis très
content
et est ce que veut bien aux valeurs ni
docteur bas nous allons examiner tout ça
je voulais vous poser russie sur
l'adaptation rayons je ne sais combien
de température cinq ans le docteur 50
c'est énorme ça cinquantaine bon ben on
va lui donner un verre de thé salines
700 arbres couchés et puis de comprimés
de strophes après produits et par là
c'est pas bien pour ta voix paul excusez
moi mais moi je sais oui mais paul
michel leschi soupapes admirons le grand
saucisson et green l etat mais tu sais
où la ville je peux emmener ma fille
d'halle card
oui certainement alors tu crois que
c'est rudy dominons nobilo
voilà il va l'entendre dans le geste fou
diront ah bonjour docteur decker alors
ombre et la croatie balade à nous allons
donc c'est pas ici c'est la maison à
côté
ah oui ici à part la fille deva s'allume
à la fille deva avec les remontrances de
spiritueux
non c'est pas la peine ils ont pas le
téléphone
écoute je faisais mon va-tout l'année
c'est pas normal devrait être rentré
pour tout l'occident mais je fais là
escalade vous croyez vraiment que c'est
le moment de faire des salles à tomber
comme des pour ted
vous allez aimer toutes les données
comment parle plus comme ça c'est
quelque chose quand même qu'il y en a
c'est assez bon g fit wii vous admirer
toutes les deux un point c'est tout et
c'est moi qui décide donc ça sens et ça
je sais qui m'a foutu des disputes de
spies je le voulais je perde mon boulot
et tout un pur cynisme et cheveux j'ai
assez inquiets et commence à jouer au
mans ça c'était offrir des films comme
ça on n'en voit pas beaucoup
[Musique]
alors oui ça c'est table en ballon vieux
je suis encore dessus oh mais tu peux
pas savoir une journée dingue métal et a
confisqué parenté du lycée s'il allait
n'ont pas eu
on va plaisante pas c'est pas fait une
grosse déprime
bon bah tu les as les premiers dessins
julien deux apporté laisse continuer mon
jeu je continue ouais bah je m'en
souviendrai de comptes solides au et de
la tour de pise
ouais c'est ça ben ça va dit même pas si
c'est bien oui oui c'est moi vous avez
parfaitement bien dans sa lettre
s'il coûte web riches soutient le père
de paul salette qua non c'est pas vrai
j'arrive
on va merde on va manger plus que ça
[Musique]
on m'a appelé je suis bien marche à
l'aide je suis bien là sa lettre m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est le père laissez moi je suis
l'agent de sécurité de la snipe
montreuil
vous a pas prévenu plus tôt voulait pas
donner son adresse bref parler
[Musique]
que si tu
le site classé
[Musique]
et voilà alors
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est ce
qu'on fait comment ça qu'est ce qu'on
fait oh mais c'est cette fois là où
comprenait ce serait trop facile trop
facile
je vais déjà établi une fiche vous voyez
une fiche maintenant il me reste à
prévenir le commissariat et la procédure
trop facile
connaissez rien
quand même je sais bien si tout le monde
comme ça hop
bon d'accord mais commissariat ça me
paraît quand même un peu ça me paraît et
oui monsieur le commissariat vous les
brouillards et avec eux classique
les enfants eux un moyen par balmont
vieux écoutez c'est la première fois
qu'on m'a peut-être lui donner une
chance
ça se fait ça croyez pas non à une
chance je sais pas mais je crois que je
crois que c'est pour la première fois ou
montrait quoi une chance
remarquez que étant donné que c'est la
première fois qu'il m'a bien dit que
c'était la première fois
oui oui oui bon en tout cas on regarde
la fiche elle va être diffusé dans tous
nos magasins avec photos ça c'est sûr
bon ça y'a un petit coup blier compte
tenu qu'on à faire un premier délit mais
parce que je suis bon prince est en
travaux on voulait
le monsieur ne nous reste plus qu à vous
remercier pour votre compréhension à
l'égard de mon fils et de la situation
quant à monfils il n'est pas prêt de
recommencer je peux vous l'assurer mais
vous dire que si j'avais prévenu les
commissariats il aurait traîné ça toute
sa vie toute sa vie et qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec les cassettes
oui comment ça qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
les cassettes
elle voit les produits si les points ah
oui prenez vous les prenez pour arena
pour 104 fronton 104 ans oui cinquième
rang bah oui qu'est ce que c'était les
cassettes
presley par la presse mais c'est pas
vraiment ce qui se pressaient pour
marquer je dis pas c'est pas bien non
non non simplement six mois' année piqué
quelque chose non je dirai qui tu es si
j'achetais quelque chose serait pas ça
bon bah c'est ce qu'on fait dans ce cas
là généralement est généralement les
parents pour les abords sont dix
alors c'est ça que des parents font
généralement oui messieurs c'est pas
notre truc
heureusement qu'il a pas fourré un
système vidéo cassettes dans un pantalon
un marxiste ont quand même ça étrange
parce qu'alors il suffit de piquer et en
fin de compte on finit par avoir ce
qu'on a piqué c'est bizarre quand on a
laissé tomber les ans les officiels
commissariat et où vous prenez les
moines ont expliqué les parents prennent
généralement la marchandise parce que
l'enfant à chaque fois qu'il entendra ce
qu'il a tenté de voler l'oreille vous
comprenez il se rappellera l'événement
un roman continuelle si vous préférez
pas d'oubli
chaque fai qui mettra presley snack
attention je le ferai plus remords j'ai
été mauvais
et classique évidemment dans ce cas là
je vois pas intéressant très très très
intéressant 104 ans leur mort éternelle
pour 104 ans évidemment pas écouté voilà
je suis pas sûr d'avoir un mollet
[Musique]
doit pas rester derrière on est tous les
2 mois était pas envie de s'asseoir à
côté de moi
[Musique]
voilà
regarde moi si toutes les écoutes moi
vous ai-je pas le genre à te faire la
peau des fesses ou violet comme un homme
quand même avoir un gros sur la patate
premièrement les couches
cette fois c'est la première fois je
suis sorti de là c'est normal la
prochaine fois je dors commissariat et
tous trois autres choses
très important
ça j'aimerais que tu comprennes
tel était le fils d'un papa l'ayant
droit ou d'un manoeuvre algérien même le
fusain pour l'eau la priorité aux
plaques
enfin et ça aussi il faudrait aussi tu
comprennes
pas entièrement responsable
notre société enfin alors tout ce qui
nous entoure on dirait que tout est
exposé pour tenter les gens et c'est
fait pour ça qu'ils achètent pas pour
qu'ils veulent
dans des fois les gens confondent
octobre
toi t'as confondues
voilà
et tu va me rembourser ils sont 4 en 1
les 100 essence et dieu il ya bien une
centaine de carreaux la maison un bar
raison d'un fonds par car ou tu la
gagnes et à les nettoyer et tout membre
sera pas
mes fils me to garapon fait bien sympa
du terran pas terrien c'est un peu
contre nous deux ça qui me i'm a man
d'amer au maire d'orly nom de dieu le
dieu le dieu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
prochaine
[Musique]
voilà
fais moi du port je me suis vraiment
fait du combat sans relâche de wet
épaules en chine et qu'elle était page
et de l'ignon pas du tout on a raté de
prendre voilà moi j'étais prêt j'avais
même préparer ses affaires à paul crois
qu'il fait remercie non j'adore ça ici
allez mettez la table on va se
débrouiller longue
ouais tu dormiras avec moi dans ma
chambre
on verra ça tout à l'heure allez mettez
la table si koné qui bat les tours le
tour sont bouleversés perdre puisque tu
appartiens
et moi j'en retiens un gâteau ouais on
est vachement très fermé des mamans bien
sûr mais avant j'ai encore une surprise
dans la
[Musique]
tiens en voilà ça c'est pour les rois
exagérons rien en tout cas celui là qui
est capital en quoi celui là je peux
faire et ça se fait bien bas monde lire
tous les supports
je vous mets partout pour ménard et ont
promis
et pour ma grande
j'aime beaucoup sa couleur mauve à extra
et c'est tout non mais vous croyez
vraiment bien voilà une fois chacun
c'est une maquette
comment se trouve cela je vais lancer et
gérer les langues c'est un super homme
regarde quand même
investor mais elle baisse reste en tout
cas j'ai compris mes envies avec
l'énergie solaire
[Musique]
quoiqu'il et demi après les faits
y'a pas nous pour doit vraiment en
retard vous et faire on est allés au
cinéma
ah bon qu'est ce que vous avez fait et
c'est une classique
ouais c'est un classique
[Musique]
blatter
[Musique]
on
nous
chaque roue tourne
[Musique]
et
l'état
je
[Musique]
m
oh
[Musique]